as soon as you start to
you know get your self-worth from those
kinds of external things
um
your world becomes so difficult whereas
if you stay in yourself and you know
that you're enough whether you're
working or not working whether your
movie did great
or it didn't do great and the other
attitude that I always have and maybe
this is goes back to the first story
about Kristen is
I it matters to me the impact I have on
an actual set
um as a human being with the crew with
the cast
um for me if I look at every job that
I've done I I probably wouldn't be able
to tell you much about what it it's
about or I mean obviously Matrix and
Memento probably you know some things of
course because I've had to talk about
them so much but but what I remember are
the relationships I had with different
crew members different things that
happened babies that were born
um you know family members that died
like
um those are the things that I remember
when I watched oh yeah I remember that
day that happened like
you are an anomaly do you understand
this no I'm not I'm not I'm not you are
an anomaly I I I just I am the opposite
of that and and try have tried and have
improved where I didn't get that
validation at home I didn't get that
love I didn't get that unconditional
feeling that you know you had that you
carried with you and so I looked for
external things I looked for if I got
this part uh I'm good it must mean I'm
good everybody likes me my age are happy
people are happy and then it's a success
and then oh it's uh par okay I but it's
like you know I always say it's like
yeah and I had a head moment listen I
had moments of that too
um especially in the beginning and I
just decided pretty early on that that
was a really shitty way to live yep it
is and so like and and to be honest like
I would have people that didn't really
believe that this was genuine like what
I'm talking about because maybe they
hadn't seen it but I believed that if a
job had my name on it it was mine and
that I had to show up and do the work
but if it had your name on it then that
was your your destiny like I brought
this sort of larger view
um
not only because
I
it felt good to do that but I knew that
I wouldn't be able to handle the
rejection and all of those things if I
was holding on or you know com I'm a
very competitive person
but I'm not competitive in that way like
if I want a job like I want to get that
job but I adding this layer of faith in
my journey just it just makes everything
it makes you so much more relaxed when
you walk into the room it makes you
because I I've gone into rooms really
wanting a job and thinking you know it's
gonna like I need the money and and you
know people will think I'm good and you
know all those things it doesn't feel
good
so I just was like okay so I want to do
this I'm here I'm making enough money
you know and I'm so lucky I'm in that
small percentage of people who actually
make enough money to pay my bills and I
don't have to have another job yet
um but like how am I gonna actually do
this and keep doing it
and I was like I'm gonna have to crack
this code
I'm gonna have to crack the code that if
I'm on my couch and I'm not working that
I know that I'm enough
and that was not easy to do but it
became the work